This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Last year, SiriusXM launched a podcast subscription that gets you ad-free listening to 99PI, plus special bonus episodes. These bonus episodes have featured extended cuts, Q&As, peeks behind the scenes of making 99PI, and some more informal chats with the crew here. Those are my favorites. After we finished up the Power Broker, a bunch of people on the Discord were asking us what other books we've been reading. So a group of us got together on Zoom and presented some of our recent favorites.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是 Roman Mars。去年，SiriusXM 推出了播客订阅服务，让你能免广告收听 99PI，并获得特别的奖励剧集。这些奖励剧集包括加长剪辑、问答环节、99PI 制作幕后花絮，以及我们团队成员之间更随意的聊天。这些是我最喜欢的。在完成《权力掮客》(The Power Broker) 之后，Discord 上的很多人问我们还在读什么书。于是我们一群人在 Zoom 上聚在一起，分享了我们最近最喜欢的一些书。
And the choices were so good and surprising and everyone was so charming. I felt like sharing this bonus episode with the wider 99PI audience. Enjoy. Hello to SiriusXM Podcast plus subscribers. This is Roman Mars here with a fun bonus episode for you. The 99PI team reads a lot. We read for research, we read for story ideas,
大家的推荐非常棒，令人惊喜，每个人也都很有魅力。我觉得应该把这期奖励剧集分享给更广泛的 99PI 听众。希望你们喜欢。向 SiriusXM Podcast Plus 的订阅用户问好。我是 Roman Mars，这期有趣的奖励剧集是专门为你们准备的。99PI 团队阅读量很大。我们为了调研而阅读，为了寻找故事灵感而阅读，
and of course we read for fun. So we thought that this month it'd be fun to talk about the books that we're currently reading, and maybe we'll give you some gift ideas for the beautiful nerds in your life. So we have a whole mix of producers on the Zoom call with me, and I'm gonna start with Lash Madan.
当然，我们也为了乐趣而阅读。所以我们觉得这个月聊聊我们正在读的书会很有趣，也许还能为你生活中那些可爱的书呆子们提供一些礼物灵感。现在 Zoom 通话里有几位制作人，我先从 Lash Madan 开始。
Lash, what are you reading right now? Hello, Roman. So I, at any given moment, am always reading three to seven books at the same time. Every morning I like to sit down with my coffee in my reading chair and sit down for 15, 20 minutes and pick a book from my stack of books in progress at random. That stack right now has short fiction, poetry, a memoir, it has communist speculative oral history, all sorts of things. But I got
Lash，你现在在读什么？你好，Roman。我随时都在同时读三到七本书。每天早上，我喜欢坐在我的阅读椅上，喝着咖啡，花 15 到 20 分钟，从我那堆正在阅读的书里随机挑一本。那堆书里现在有短篇小说、诗歌、回忆录、共产主义推测性口述历史，各种各样的东西。但我
decision fatigue and struggled with picking one book from the stack, so I decided to, instead of telling you about books in progress, I want to talk to you about a book that's been sitting on my shelf for the last four years, I've actually never read it fully cover to cover, but I keep revisiting it every couple months. And my relationship to this book is actually really connected to my work on this show. Okay. So one thing I love about being a producer is that there's so many different phases of a production process, right? There's the pitching, the researching, interviewing, writing, scoring.
产生了决策疲劳，很难从那堆书里选出一本，所以我决定，与其告诉你我正在读什么，不如聊聊一本在我书架上放了四年，但我从未从头到尾读完，却每隔几个月就会重读的书。我和这本书的关系其实与我在这档节目的工作密切相关。好的。作为一名制作人，我喜欢的一点是制作过程有很多不同的阶段，对吧？有选题、调研、采访、写作、配乐。
The hardest phase for me is that brief window of time when I've submitted a first draft to an editor and it's in their hands, they're reading it, tearing it up with notes. And in this window of time, I cannot look at my laptop or my phone. You know, when someone's editing the Google Doc and you get all the notifications? Right, right, right. That's horrible. So ever since my first story on the show, I started doing something that has sort of, it kind of unintentionally became a ritual in this very particular timeframe.
对我来说最困难的阶段是那个短暂的窗口期：当我把初稿交给编辑，稿子在他们手里，他们正在阅读并用批注把它改得面目全非的时候。在这个时间段里，我不能看我的笔记本电脑或手机。你知道，当有人在编辑 Google 文档时，你会收到所有通知，对吧？没错，没错。那太可怕了。所以自从我为节目制作第一个故事以来，我就开始做一些事情，在这一特定时期，它无意中变成了一种仪式。
I'll hand in a script, close my laptop, and I'll pickle something. Pete Slauson Like literally? Anna Slauson Literally, I will pickle anything I find in my house. It's like a distraction mechanism to stop getting anxious about how my editor is reacting to my script. Pete Slauson Okay. Anna Slauson And maybe it's because my first story was during peak pandemic and everyone was talking about fermentation. But I just needed something to do with my hands.
我会交出剧本，合上笔记本电脑，然后去腌制点什么。Pete Slauson：真的吗？Anna Slauson：真的，我会腌制我在家里找到的任何东西。这就像是一种分散注意力的机制，让我不再为编辑对我的剧本会有什么反应而焦虑。Pete Slauson：好吧。Anna Slauson：也许是因为我的第一个故事是在疫情高峰期，当时每个人都在谈论发酵。但我只是需要找点事情做，让手忙起来。
And so the book that I'm constantly revisiting every time I work on a story for the show is called Usha's Pickle Digest, the Perfect Pickle Recipe Book. And I want to tell you about this woman, Usha. This woman is known on the internet as the Pickle Queen of India. In 1998, she self-published this Pickling Encyclopedia. It's not a modern cookbook. You can tell it was published on Microsoft Word. The foreword to the book was faxed to the publisher
所以，每次我为节目制作故事时，我都会不断重读的那本书叫《乌莎的腌菜文摘：完美腌菜食谱》(Usha's Pickle Digest, the Perfect Pickle Recipe Book)。我想和你们聊聊这位叫乌莎的女士。她在互联网上被称为“印度腌菜女王”。1998 年，她自费出版了这本《腌制百科全书》。这不是一本现代食谱。你可以看出它是用 Microsoft Word 排版的。这本书的序言是传真给出版商的，
and just tacked into the book. There are over 1,000 pickle recipes in there and it reads like a textbook, like there's only text and no images. I don't know if you'll be able to see, but I'm just going to hold the cover up for you just so you can see how old school it looks. It has real self-published vibes for sure. Yeah. So this book, it actually has a cult following, but Usha never meant to publish a pickle book.
然后直接贴在书里的。里面有 1000 多种腌菜食谱，读起来像教科书，只有文字，没有图片。我不知道你们能不能看到，但我把封面举起来给你们看看，让你们感受一下它有多老派。它确实有一种自费出版的氛围。是的。所以这本书其实有一批忠实的追随者，但乌莎从未想过要出版一本腌菜书。
And I find that whole story really charming. She's a retired lawyer now in her 70s. And it started for her as a collection of 25 or so pickle recipes that she scribbled into a notebook to pass on to her friends and family. And over time, the number of recipes grew and grew and a book started to make logical sense. But even then, the purpose of the book to her was to conveniently share all her recipes with friends and family.
我觉得整个故事非常迷人。她现在是一位 70 多岁的退休律师。最初，她只是把大约 25 个腌菜食谱写在笔记本上，传给朋友和家人。随着时间的推移，食谱的数量越来越多，出一本书在逻辑上就变得顺理成章了。但即便如此，对她来说，这本书的目的也只是为了方便地与亲友分享她的食谱。
Which is why when she published this book in 1998, she only printed 1,000 copies and gave them all out for free. And for years, finding a hard copy of this book was a real challenge because Usha just wasn't printing them. The only way to get one was to email her herself. But for years, shortly after the book was published, Usha suffered a health condition and she would respond to the email saying, I promise to get you a copy soon. Some cooks and fans couldn't wait. They started self photocopying pages and passing them around.
这就是为什么她在 1998 年出版这本书时，只印了 1000 本，并且全部免费赠送。多年来，找到这本书的纸质版是一个真正的挑战，因为乌莎根本不再印刷了。唯一的获取方式就是给她本人发电子邮件。但在书出版后不久的几年里，乌莎身体状况不佳，她会回复邮件说：“我保证很快给你寄一本。”有些厨师和粉丝等不及了，他们开始自己复印页面并传阅。
And Usha was supposedly like, great. And eventually when she got healthier, she'd email people back with a free PDF of her book whenever they asked. So it kind of passed around the world in this way as an email attachment. And I love the book because it has the essence of an extremely comprehensive Google doc passed around by an auntie who just wants you to know how to make things taste good. And I think that's why I love it. It's amazing. I love this story.
据说乌莎对此表示：“太好了。”最终，当她身体好转时，每当有人索要，她就会通过电子邮件回复一份免费的 PDF 文档。所以它就这样以电子邮件附件的形式在世界各地流传。我喜欢这本书，因为它有一种极其详尽的 Google 文档的精髓，就像一位只想让你知道如何让食物变得美味的阿姨传给你的东西。我想这就是我喜欢它的原因。太棒了。我喜欢这个故事。
Like I think this should almost be a story for the show. Although what would you do when the script was being edited? It's like- I know, right? Yeah. I don't want to cannibalize your safe haven that you go to when you're not thinking about stories.
我觉得这几乎可以成为我们节目的一个故事。虽然当剧本正在编辑时你会做什么？我知道，对吧？是的。我不想破坏你不想故事时去的那片避风港。
But this is such a great idea. Usha's Pickle Digest, the perfect pickle recipe book. That's amazing. Well, thank you so much for sharing that. I love this. Yeah, and I should say that even though historically this book has been hard to get ahold of because there's been so few copies going around, it did four or five years ago come online. So you actually can buy this now as a gift for someone you love, and I would highly recommend that.
但这真是个好主意。《乌莎的腌菜文摘：完美腌菜食谱》。太神奇了。好吧，非常感谢你的分享。我喜欢这个。是的，我应该说，虽然从历史上看，这本书因为流传的副本很少而很难买到，但四五年前它已经上线了。所以你现在确实可以把它作为礼物买给你爱的人，我强烈推荐。
Could I just read, like, rattle off a couple different possible pickles you could possibly make? Absolutely. Okay. I recently made a sweet and sour orange peel pickle, watermelon rind pickle. There's jackfruit pickle. You could pickle gooseberries or lotus stems or banana flowers. Like really anything. I think that yeah, nothing escapes pickling for Usha.
我能读一下，列举几个你可能制作的腌菜种类吗？当然。好的。我最近做了酸甜橙皮腌菜、西瓜皮腌菜。还有菠萝蜜腌菜。你可以腌制醋栗、莲藕或香蕉花。真的什么都可以。我想是的，对乌莎来说，没有什么逃得过腌制。
Yeah, I mean, I guess not. Yeah, I just love that so much. I love it. I love it. I think this is the perfect gift for anybody, just because it's like, in and of itself, the book is this amazing story, which is so cool. Well, anyway, well, that's awesome. Thank you so much.
是的，我想也是。是的，我太喜欢这个了。我喜欢它。我喜欢它。我觉得这是送给任何人的完美礼物，因为它本身就是一个精彩的故事，这太酷了。好吧，无论如何，这太棒了。非常感谢。
Everyone has a lot to live up to, because that's almost a story in and of itself. So thank you, Lasha. I appreciate it. Yeah, thanks. Okay. Up next is Chris Berube. Chris, what book do you have for the Nine MPI audience? Well, Roman, this year I've been reading a book that I think our audience will get a lot out of. It's called The Power Broker by Robert Caro. Really interesting book about urbanism and history. I read it this year for the second time, because we were doing it, and have had a great time reading it all over again.
每个人都有很高的标准要达到，因为这本身几乎就是一个故事。所以谢谢你，Lasha。我很感激。是的，谢谢。好的。接下来是 Chris Berube。Chris，你为 99PI 的听众准备了什么书？嗯，Roman，今年我一直在读一本书，我觉得我们的听众会从中受益匪浅。它叫《权力掮客》，作者是 Robert Caro。关于城市规划和历史的非常有趣的书。我今年读了第二遍，因为我们正在做相关内容，重读一遍感觉很棒。
But may I recommend another huge book I've been reading if you need another thousand page plus nonfiction piece to fill that void in your heart. It's called What It Takes? The Way to the White House by Richard Ben Kramer. Have you ever read this book, Roman? I have not. No.
但我可以推荐另一本我一直在读的大部头吗？如果你需要另一本一千多页的非虚构作品来填补你心中的空虚。它叫《胜算：通往白宫之路》(What It Takes: The Way to the White House)，作者是 Richard Ben Kramer。你读过这本书吗，Roman？我没有。没有。
Okay. Do you know what it's about? No. No. So, yeah, please tell me more. Yes. This book is another gigantic tome, another one that looms large for people who are politics nerds.
好的。你知道它是关于什么的吗？不知道。不。所以，请多告诉我一些。是的。这本书是另一部巨著，对于政治书呆子来说，它是一部很有分量的作品。
It's about the 1988 presidential race. So the book follows all of the candidates running in the primaries. So it's like Dukakis, Joe Biden, and on the Republican side, Bush and Bob Dole. And it gives you very interesting histories of all these people. Basically, I think the takeaway is that all of these people are kind of monomaniacal. Like anyone who wants to be the president has to have something that's a little deficient in their personality is kind of the take of the book. It's very interesting to have read this during the election this year. Obviously to read a contemporary history, it is interesting to compare all the ways that things are different and the way things are the same.
它是关于 1988 年总统竞选的。这本书追踪了所有参加初选的候选人。比如杜卡基斯、乔·拜登，共和党方面的布什和鲍勃·多尔。它为你提供了所有这些人非常有趣的历史。基本上，我认为结论是这些人都有点偏执。就像任何想成为总统的人，他们的性格中都必须有一些缺陷，这是这本书的观点。在今年的选举期间读这本书非常有趣。显然，阅读当代历史，比较事物变化的方式以及保持不变的方式，是很有趣的。
For this one, it's a lot of stuff is very different, especially reading about the Republican Party in the late 80s, because their two candidates are like George HW Bush, who's this kind of country club, patrician Republican. And on the other side, Bob Dole, who is just obsessed with the deficit and is like, we just have to cut, you know, as much as we can to get the debt under control. And neither of those types of Republicans is like relevant at all right now. Yeah. So that's super interesting.
对于这一本，很多东西都非常不同，特别是读到 80 年代末的共和党时，因为他们的两位候选人，一位是乔治·H·W·布什，那种乡村俱乐部式的贵族共和党人；另一边是鲍勃·多尔，他只关心赤字，说：“我们必须尽可能削减开支，以控制债务。”而这两种共和党人现在一点都不相关了。是的。所以这超级有趣。
One thing I really took away from this book, when Republicans talk about Ronald Reagan, and they did it during this election too, they always talk about Ronald Reagan as like the greatest figure in their party. It's like Lincoln and Reagan, those are the two great Republicans ever. Reading this book from 1988,
我从这本书中真正学到的一点是，当共和党人谈论罗纳德·里根时——他们在这次选举中也这样做——他们总是把里根称为他们党内最伟大的人物。就像林肯和里根，这是有史以来最伟大的两位共和党人。读这本 1988 年的书，
it is very clear that at the time, Republicans did not like Ronald Reagan. They really hated Ronald Reagan. So I have a quote that I wrote down. This is from Bob Dole, who was at the time the leader of the Republican conference in the Senate. And this is what he said about the president from his own party. Bob Dole used to tell a joke to the people that he worked with. He said, boys, there was good news last night, a bus full of supply siders, such supply side economics people like the people in Reagan's camp, a bus full of supply siders went off a cliff last night and everyone died. There's bad news. There were three empty
很明显，当时共和党人并不喜欢罗纳德·里根。他们真的很讨厌罗纳德·里根。所以我写下了一句引语。这是鲍勃·多尔说的，他当时是参议院共和党会议的领袖。这就是他对自己党内总统的评价。鲍勃·多尔过去常给同事讲个笑话。他说：“伙计们，昨晚有个好消息，一辆载满供给学派支持者（比如里根阵营里那些支持供给侧经济学的人）的巴士昨晚冲下了悬崖，所有人都死了。坏消息是，车上有三个空
seats on the bus. So this is within his own party at this point, he has so thoroughly lost his own conference that people are like, we got to get past Reagan. Like there's sections in the book about how campaigning for the Senate in 1986, people were like, don't send Reagan, don't send Reagan to campaign for us. We don't want him here. So it's really interesting to read these contemporary histories to sort of see how they've been tweaked and revised over time. And yeah, even within the Republican Party at that time, next time you hear Ronald Reagan,
座位。”所以，在这一点上，在他自己的党内，他已经彻底失去了自己的会议，以至于人们说：“我们必须超越里根。”书里有章节提到，在 1986 年竞选参议员时，人们说：“别派里根来，别派里根来为我们竞选。我们不想要他在这里。”所以阅读这些当代历史，看看它们是如何随着时间的推移被调整和修正的，真的很有趣。是的，即使在当时的共和党内部，下次你听到罗纳德·里根，
the great Republican president, just remember what Bob Dole said about supply-siders going over a cliff in a bus. So, What It Takes by Richard Ben Kramer, really a very readable, compelling book if you need just a gigantic non-fiction thing to fill the place that the power broker was holding for you this year. I love it.
那位伟大的共和党总统，请记住鲍勃·多尔关于供给学派支持者坐巴士冲下悬崖的笑话。所以，《胜算》，作者 Richard Ben Kramer，如果你需要一本巨大的非虚构作品来填补今年《权力掮客》留下的空缺，这是一本非常可读、引人入胜的书。我喜欢它。
This is kind of perfect. I'm surprised I haven't heard of this more. I don't know why I haven't, but I just, I don't, I haven't heard of this more. I don't know why I haven't, but I just, but I really, um, this is a, this is amazing. I would be, I'm going to pick this one up for sure. Totally. I, you know, I think is it probably because the 88 election doesn't really feel important anymore, right? Like it's like Bush was a one-term president, right? And like we don't really think about his presidency as an era the way that we do with Reagan or Clinton or Obama
这简直太完美了。我很惊讶我没有更多地听说过它。我不知道为什么，但我就是没怎么听说过。我不知道为什么，但我真的，嗯，这太棒了。我肯定会买这一本。当然。你知道，我想这可能是因为 88 年的选举感觉不再重要了，对吧？就像布什是一个任期总统，对吧？我们不像对待里根、克林顿、奥巴马那样把他的总统任期视为一个时代
or Trump now. Yeah. I think that's right. I mean, like when I'm looking like on Amazon where this book is like paired with this books like Game Change and things that I'm a little bit more familiar with, it's also possible that it's just because it came out in the early 90s,
或者现在的特朗普。是的。我想是对的。我的意思是，当我在亚马逊上看到这本书与《游戏改变》(Game Change) 之类的书放在一起时，那些我更熟悉一些，也可能是因为它是在 90 年代初出版的，
which I was in college then. And so therefore I have a kind of a cultural black hole familiar with. It's also possible that it's just because it came out in the early 90s, which I was in college then, and so therefore I have a kind of a cultural black hole during the periods of 1990 to 94 that if it was really, really, you know, if it was really, really big at that moment, I didn't, I was not paying attention at that moment. So, but this looks amazing. I'm super excited to check it out. Well, thank you. Well, enjoy. Absolutely, Roman. I'm super excited to check it out. Well, thank you. Well, enjoy. Absolutely, Roman. I hope you have some great fun reading time ahead
那时我还在上大学。因此，我有一个文化盲点。也可能是因为它是在 90 年代初出版的，那时我还在上大学，所以我在 1990 到 1994 年期间有一个文化盲点，如果它在当时真的很火，我当时并没有注意。所以，但这看起来太棒了。我超级兴奋去看看。好吧，谢谢。祝你阅读愉快。当然，Roman。我超级兴奋去看看。好吧，谢谢。祝你阅读愉快。当然，Roman。希望你在假期里和你家人一起度过一段美好的阅读时光。我很感激。谢谢。好的，接下来是我们的制作人 Vivian Ley。嘿，Vivian。Roman Mars，你好吗？我很好。那么你现在在读什么书？
over the holidays for you and your family. I appreciate that. Thanks. Okay, so up next is our producer, Vivian Ley. Hey, Vivian. Roman Mars, how are you doing? I'm great. So what book are you reading right now?
好的，我是一个不太爱读书的人。我不喜欢阅读。当我读的时候，通常是那种非常低俗的浪漫小说。你刚好在我确实在读几本书的时候抓住了我。我不羞于在广播里说出来。我其实正在读三本书，但我可能永远读不完，因为我同时读三本，而且我注意力不集中，我一直在轮换。我可能要花三年时间才能读完。但早上，我一直在读一本叫《轨道》(Orbital) 的书，作者是 Samantha Harvey。这是一本发生在 24 小时内的书。它是国际空间站上一群宇航员的生活。
Okay, so I am a not very literate person. I do not like to read. When I do, it is usually like a really smutty romance book. You just happened to catch me at a time that I actually am reading books. I'm not embarrassed to say on the air. And I'm reading actually three books right now, which I will probably never finish because I'm reading three and I have a short attention span and I keep rotating them. I might finish them in like three years. But so in the mornings, I have been reading a book called Orbital by Samantha Harvey. It's a book that takes place over 24 hours. And it's the life of a group of astronauts on an international
是的，而且没有情节。它有点像《火星救援》，但没有那些东西，比如没有科学之类的。它有科学，有对生活的沉思，而且非常诗意。它只是关于自然，是的，它真的很美，而且非常具有冥想性。所以这是我早上一直在读的东西，算是为我的一天定下基调。我不是一个对火星很感兴趣的人。这对我来说是一个危险信号。如果你说你想去火星，我会说：“不，抱歉，去跟别人谈吧。”是的，是的，是的。
space station. And yeah, and there's there's no plot. It's kind of like the Martian, but without all the stuff like there's no science and stuff. It's got the science and it's got meditations on life and it's got, you know, it's very poetic. And it's just about like nature and yeah, it's really beautiful and it's very meditative. So it's something that I've been reading in the morning, kind of like scene set my day. I am not someone who's very interested in Mars. That's kind of a red flag for me. If you say that you want to go to Mars, I'm like, no, sorry, talk to somebody else. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
或者请直接去，别跟我说话。是的，完全正确。是的。但以这种方式阅读关于太空的书，让你感觉自己既非常宏大又非常渺小。所以这只是开启我早晨的一种不错的方式。是的，睡前，我一直在读一本叫《殉道者》(Martyr) 的书，作者是 Kava Akbar。你可能听说过这一本。这是今年的一本大作。这是我书架上我想读的一本书，因为它是那种
Or just please go and don't talk to me. Yes, exactly. Yeah. But there's something about like reading about space in this way that makes you feel very big and very small at the same time. So it's just a nice way to set my morning. Yeah, before bed, I've been reading a book called Martyr by Kava Akbar. You probably heard about this one. This one has been a big one this year. This is one that's on that's on my shelf that I want to read because it's the it's the type
我不读非虚构作品时非常喜欢的书。是的，我读了很多小说。我喜欢小说。但它真的很不可思议。读起来非常有趣。听起来不像是一本有趣的读物。它是关于一位焦虑的伊朗裔美国作家，他最近刚戒酒，他寻找一位身患绝症的艺术家，她最后的艺术作品本质上是在博物馆里死去。听起来并不乐观，但它出奇地乐观。它从多个角色的视角出发，他们都在寻找生命的意义。但它真的很棒，而且在奇怪的地方非常有趣，感觉非常新鲜。所以我真的
of book I like a lot when I'm not reading non-fiction. Yes, I read a lot of fiction. I love fiction. But yeah, it's it's incredible. It's a really fun read. It doesn't sound like it's a fun read. It is about an angsty Iranian American writer who you know is recently sober and he seeks out this artist who's terminally ill and her last artwork is essentially dying in a museum. And it doesn't sound upbeat, but it's weirdly upbeat. It's from the perspective of multiple characters who are kind of like searching for the meaning of life. But yeah, it's really fun and really funny in odd ways and it just, it feels very fresh. So I really
向那些今年想找一本让人爱不释手的书的人推荐它。太棒了。好吧，我会把它放在我书单的更前面，因为这是我一直放在那里并且很期待的一本。太棒了。是的，那本很值得。鉴于选举，我一直在重读尼尔·波兹曼的《娱乐至死》(Amusing Ourselves to Death)。这是我目前正在听的最后一本书。
recommend that for people who are looking for like a page turner this year. Awesome. Well, I'll put that more to the top of for like a page turn this year. Awesome. I'll put that more to the top of my queue because it's been one that's been sitting there that I've been excited about. That's awesome. Yeah, that one holds up. In light of the election, I have been revisiting Amusing Ourselves to Death by Neil Postman. This is the last book that I'm kind of listening to right now.
我正在听有声书。这是一本 1985 年的老书。人们可能以前听说过它。它是关于电视和电子媒体对政治的影响，以及它是如何将新闻变成娱乐，从而永远破坏话语权的。你大概能想象为什么我此刻要重读它。
I'm listening to the audiobook. And this is an old one from like 1985. People have probably heard of it before. It's about the effects of television and electronic media on politics and how it's turning news into entertainment and that's ruining discourse forever. You can probably imagine why I'm revisiting it at this moment.
完全同意。我一直想到这个标题。是的。所以，我做饭时一直在听有声书。这种体验就像你给 Joe Rosenberg 喝了三杯威士忌，然后问他话语权出了什么问题，他就会对着你滔滔不绝讲三个半小时，就是那种感觉。
Totally. I think of this title all the time. Yeah. So yeah, I've been listening to the audiobook when I cook. And the experience is kind of like if you gave Joe Rosenberg like three shots of whiskey and you just asked him what's wrong with discourse and you just kind of talked at you for like three and a half hours, that's what it's like.
所以如果你想要那种体验，去看看吧。我就在这里，Vivian。哦，我知道。我知道。而且你知道这是真的，Joe。无可奉告。无可奉告。太棒了。但我确实有一个关于低俗浪漫小说的额外推荐，如果人们在找的话。哦，是的。当然。告诉我们吧。是的。
So if you want that experience, check that out. I'm right here Vivian. Oh, I know. I know. And you know this is true, Joe. No comment. No comment. So great. But I do have one bonus recommendation for a smutty romance if people are looking for one. Oh, yeah. Sure. Lay it on us. Yeah.
是的。我今年读了 Yuen Quang 的《如何结束一段爱情》(How to End a Love Story)，非常喜欢。所以，是的，它有一点关于创伤的内容。所以这里有一点警告。但它感觉有点沉重，但读起来真的很不错，而且它对与亚裔父母吵架然后和好的描写非常准确。所以如果你是亚裔美国人，请记住这一点。太棒了。好吧，这些推荐太棒了。对于一个说自己不读书的人来说，你读了很多高质量的东西。
Yeah. I read this year and really enjoyed How to End a Love Story by Yuen Quang. So yeah, it's about trauma a little bit. So just a little bit of a warning there But it's it's so it feels a little bit heavier, but it's a really nice read and it has one of the most accurate representations of what it's like to fight with your Asian parents and then Make up from that fight. So if you're an Asian American person, just you know, I go into that with with that in mind great Well, this is these are fantastic recommendations. For someone who says they don't read, you're reading a lot of good quality things.
这完全是个巧合。老实说，是的。不然我会在隔壁房间重看《吉尔莫女孩》。太棒了。我要做一个正式的总结，以防大家在做笔记。所以是 Samantha Harvey 的《轨道》，Kava Akbar 的《殉道者》，尼尔·波兹曼的《娱乐至死》，
This is a complete coincidence. Honestly, yeah. Otherwise, I'd be watching Gilmore Girls again in the other room. That's awesome. I'm going to do a proper summary just so people are taking notes. So it's Orbital by Samantha Harvey, Martyr by Keve Akbar, Amusing Ourselves to Death
以及 Yulin Kuang 的《如何结束一段爱情》。你说对了。谢谢。太棒了。谢谢你，Vivian。休息后，我们将有来自 Jason、Joe 和我的推荐。接下来是制作人 Jason DeLeon。嘿，Jason。Roman Mars，怎么了？
by Neil Postman, and How to End a Love Story by Yulin Kuang. You got it. Thanks. Awesome. Thank you, Vivian. We have recommendations from Jason and Joe and me after the break. So up next is producer Jason DeLeon. Hey Jason. Roman Mars, what's going on?
不知道。我只是对所有这些书感到非常兴奋。我没想到我会从中学到东西。我以为我们只是为观众和听众做这件事。但现在我真的对大家推荐的所有这些书很感兴趣。好吧，我要降低一下调子。好的。因为正如团队里的人所知，
I don't know. I'm just like really excited about all these books. Like I wasn't expecting that I would learn from this. I thought we were just going to do this for the audience and the listeners out there. But like now I'm really into all these books that people are suggesting. Well, I'm going to take it down a notch here. Okay. Because as people on this team know,
我去年生了个孩子。没错，没错。她刚满一岁。所以我在这里要谈谈我正在读的一本精彩的书，我连续读了三遍，每天晚上，非常缓慢地读给她听。它叫《跳跳蛙》(Hoppity Frog)。好的。
I had a kid this past year. That's right, that's right. She just turned a year old. And so I'm here to talk about a fantastic book that I'm reading that I read three times in a row, every night, very slowly to her. It's called Hoppity Frog. Okay.
所以这只跳跳蛙，跳跳蛙在哪里？他在珊瑚里吗？不在这里，但这是一只小蝌蚪。所以我一遍又一遍地做这个。太棒了。我非常非常怀念那些日子。当你进入他们喜欢更复杂叙事的年龄时，这简直是世界上最令人耳目一新和神奇的事情。
And so this Hoppity Frog, where is hoppity frog? Is he in the coral? Not here, but this is a tiny tadpole. So I do this over and over and over again. That's awesome. I remember those days very, very, very much. When you get into the age of them liking more complex narratives, it is like the most refreshing and amazing thing
我能看到它在你身上流露。是的，突然之间，你知道，当你开始读罗尔德·达尔或者像我读特里·普拉切特，比如《猫和小子》(The Wee Free Men) 之类的书时，当孩子们发生这种情况时，我简直太兴奋了。
in the world. I can see it washing over you. Yeah, it is just like, it's all of a sudden I would, you know, when you start reading Roald Dahl or like I would, I, Terry Pratchett, like the, the We Free Men and stuff like this were, were just like, when that, when that happened with the kids, I was just like so excited.
就像我想要，我对阅读时间感到兴奋，就像那样，你知道，你大部分时间对此感到兴奋，但你一遍又一遍地读同样的东西，它确实会进入你的大脑。就像咒语一样。是的，是的。无论如何，但更严肃地说，
Like I wanted, I was excited about reading Time Versus, like that's, you know, like you're happened with the kids, I was just like so excited. Like I wanted, I was excited about reading time versus like that's, you know, like you're mostly excited about it, but you read the same thing again and again, it does sort of like get into your brain. It's like an incantation. Yeah, yeah. Anyway, but on a more serious note,
过去一年我一直在努力寻找阅读时间，你可以想象。所以尽管我读了大约 200 本儿童读物，但我一直在努力找一本成年人的书来读。基本上为了给自己创造时间，我早上读小说，我有 15 分钟，我试着一点一点读完一本小说。晚上我读诗歌，因为到了 8:30 或 9 点，如果我休息，我就睡着了。你睡着了。
I've been struggling to find time to read in the past year, as you can imagine. And so despite the fact that I've read something like 200 children's books, I've been trying to find a grownup book to read. And basically to institute time for myself to create this time to read, I've do a novel in the morning where I have like 15 minutes and I just try to get through a novel little by little. And I do poetry at night because by 8.30 or 9 o'clock, if I'm in repose, I'm out. You're falling asleep.
完全正确。我要去睡觉了。一样，一样，一样，一样。所以我刚读完这本书。它叫《散落北方的雪》(Scattered Snows to the North)，是我最喜欢的诗人 Carl Phillips 的最新诗集。你是个喜欢诗歌的人吗，Roman？我不是，我的意思是，但这是因为缺乏接触
Totally. I'm going to bed. Same, same, same, same. And so I just finished this book. It's called Scattered Snow to the North. It's the most recent collection of poems by my favorite poet, Carl Phillips. Are you much of a poetry person, Roman? I'm not, I mean, it's, but it's because of lack of exposure
和知识。我很想成为一个更喜欢诗歌的人，所以。是的，好吧，让我们看看我至少能不能告诉你一点关于这位特定诗人的信息。让我们看看我能不能做到。因为对我来说，我不知道，我只是喜欢诗歌，因为它们需要我全神贯注，而我的注意力现在被拉向了太多方向。
and sort of knowledge. I would love to be a person who loved poetry more, so. Yeah, well, let's see if I could tell you a little bit at least on this specific poet. Let's see if I can do it. Because for me, I don't know, I just like, I love poems because they just require my full attention and my attention is so pulled in so many directions right now.
而且我以前也是个运动员，我觉得读诗就像坐着不动做运动。你几乎必须在脑海中与这种动态搏斗，非常仔细地阅读文字。你必须逐字逐句、逐行逐行地阅读，然后你再做一遍，你可以从中解读出不同的含义。我不知道，对我来说，它在那种方式上感觉很像运动。那是——这是一个惊人的比喻。
And I'm like also like a former athlete and I feel like reading poetry is like doing sports while sitting still. You have to like almost wrestle this dynamic in your head and read the words very carefully. You have to read letter by letter, word by word, line break by line break, and then you do it all over again and you can like interpret different meanings from it. I don't know, to me it feels very sport-like in that way. And so- That is an amazing metaphor.
我以前从未听说过，它让读诗突然以一种新的方式对我来说变得有意义。那是，哦，你可能已经告诉过我了。是的，是的，是的，就是这样。这就像锻炼。好吧，也许现在我不是，也许我现在卖不出去了，但是——好吧，是的，不，你可能已经告诉过我了。是的，就是这样。这就像，这就像锻炼。好吧。也许现在我不是，也许我现在卖不出去了，但是，嗯。好吧，是的，不，但我明白你的意思。我明白你的意思。
I've never heard that before, and it makes reading poetry all of a sudden make sense to me in a new kind of way. That's, oh, you might've already told me. Yeah, yeah, yeah, there we go. It's like working out. All right, well maybe now I'm not, maybe I'm not selling it now, but- Well, yeah, no, you might've already told me. Yeah, there we go. It's like, it's like working out. All right. Well, maybe now I'm not, maybe I'm not selling it now, but, um. Well, yeah, no, but I get what you mean. I get what you mean.
我，我对诗歌的问题，以及对很多东西，比如图画小说之类的，或者其他什么，就是我倾向于为了情节和信息而阅读，我不是一个真正的，我喜欢人们把有趣、酷和美丽的词放在一起，但我的习惯只是，尽快给我信息。所以把它当作一种练习的想法会让我处于正确的思维模式，我想。
I, I, my problem with poetry and for a lot of things like graphic novels and stuff too, or whatever is like, I tend to read for plot and information and I'm not a real, like I love people put together interesting and cool and beautiful words, but my habit is just like, give me the information as fast as possible. And so the idea of it being an exercise would put me in the right mindset for it, I think.
是的，这确实就是它。对我来说，我也那样读。我喜欢好的情节，我喜欢好的，所有这些东西。但有时我发现自己只是在浏览，我不是在阅读，我只是在“嗡，嗡，嗡，嗡”。这让我阅读。无论如何，Carl Phillips 的最新书，
Yeah, that's really what it is. And like for me, I also, I read that way too. I love a good plot, I love good, all that stuff. But sometimes I find myself just going through, I'm just not reading, I'm just like, vroom, vroom, vroom, vroom. And this makes me read. Anyway, so Carl Philipp's latest book,
我的意思是，他写了很多诗歌作品。到目前为止，我已经读了他的全集。他从 90 年代开始出版。我不知道这是第几本书，但这是他的最新书。他去年，两年前刚赢得了普利策奖，因为这本书叫《然后是战争》(Then the War)，这是一本不可思议的书。它真的，真的，真的非常好。这是给人们的另一个推荐。那本书是关于权力的，我想，大写的 P 权力，小写的 p 权力，各种各样的权力。一个不错的，你知道，关于权力的《权力掮客》的附录。是的。而且，我最喜欢他作品的一点是，它感觉就像一场对话
I mean, he's written a lot of poetry works. I've read his full collection now by this point. He started publishing in the 90s. I don't know which book number this is, but it's his latest book. He just won the Pulitzer last year, two years ago, for this book called Then the War, which was an incredible book. It is so, so, so very good. And that is another recommendation for people. And that book was about like power, I guess, capital P power, lowercase P power, all kinds of power. A nice, you know, addendum to the power broker about power. Yeah. And like, and the thing that I. And the thing that I like the most about his work is that it feels like a conversation
他正在进行，而我正在跟随，就像他在那一刻思考的方式。我只是跟着他思考的方式。所以上一部诗集是关于权力的。我刚读完的这一部，更多是关于质疑知识的，我想。它更像是，我们对过去的痴迷是什么？这是一个值得的努力吗？所以，就像书中的同名诗，它叫《散落北方的雪》，他是一位罗马帝国学者。所以在这首诗中，他正在质疑那种知识的效用。我要读一点点，这样你就能尝尝它的味道。
that he's having that I'm following along, like the way he's thinking in that moment. And I just kind of keep following along the way he's thinking. And so that last collection was about power. This one that I just finished reading, it's a lot more about questioning knowledge, I guess. It's a little bit more like, what is our obsession with the past? Is it a worthy endeavor? And so, like in the title poem to the book, it's called Scatterstone to the North, and he is a scholar of the Roman Empire. And so in this poem, he's questioning the utility of that knowledge. So I'm going to read just a little bit of it just so you can get a taste of it.
罗马帝国仍然处于早期阶段，缓慢地走向永不复返，这并不重要。当时和现在一样，人们难道不是在别人面前或私下里毫无理由地泪流满面吗？他们愿意给出的理由，或者他们还不能给出。所以，我不知道。我只是，他试图找到事物中心的人，并试图剥离它周围所有其他东西的力量。是的。我喜欢那个。太好了。是的。是的。然后我想我最后要说的一点是关于 Carl Phillips 的作品，以及我通常钦佩的诗人的作品，就是有时我太喜欢他们的东西了，以至于我拒绝听他们的声音。
Doesn't matter that the Roman Empire was still early and it's slow unwinding into never again. Then as now didn't people burst into tears in front of other people or in private for no reason that they were willing to give or they weren't yet able to. So, I don't know. I just kind of, he tries to find the like, the human at the center of the thing and trying to strip it of the power of all the other stuff that's around it. Yeah. I love that. That's so good. Yeah. Yeah. And then I guess one last thing I'll say about like Carl Phillips's work and just kind of the work of poets that I admire in general, is that sometimes I love their stuff so much that I refuse to hear their voice.
就像我的订阅源里有所有这些东西，说：“这是你一直在寻找作品的诗人。”你想听他们读一首诗吗？我从来，从来不想听他们读诗。我从来，从来不想听他们读诗。有趣，有趣。我只是担心如果我听到文字背后的人声，那东西就会失去魔力。所以他对我来说就是那样的人。我最好的朋友，我最好的朋友之一住得很近
Like I get all these things in my feed of being like, here's the poet that obviously you've been looking up their work and stuff. Like do you want to hear them read a poem? And I never ever want to hear them read a poem? And I never, ever want to hear them read the poem. Interesting, interesting. I'm just afraid that if I hear the human voice to the words, that the thing will lose its magic. And so he's like one of those people for me. My best friend, one of my best friends lives very close
在他住在科德角的地方。每当我去拜访时，我总是想：“我今天会遇到 Carl Phillips 吗？”那会是一件好事还是坏事？从宏观角度来看，见到他会很可爱。但我认为我不想。这太有趣了。
to where he lives on Cape Cod. And whenever I go visit, I'm always like, am I gonna run into Carl Fowler today? And would that be a good thing or a bad thing? In the grand scheme of things, it would be lovely to meet him. But I don't think I want to. That's so interesting.
好吧，这是一个很棒的推荐。我喜欢这个进入你思想的窗口，以及你如何思考。我不想。这太有趣了。好吧，这是一个很棒的推荐。我喜欢这个进入你思想的窗口，以及你如何思考和处理事情。这太酷了。所以你提到在一天中的其他时间读小说。你的小说是什么？哦，是的。我正在读的小说
Well, that's a great recommendation. I love this window into your mind and how you think I want to. That's so interesting. Well, that's a great recommendation. I love this window into your mind and how you think and process things. That's so cool. So you mentioned reading a novel in the other part of the day. What's your novel? Oh, yeah. My novel that I'm reading right now
是这本叫《停电》(Blackouts) 的书，作者是 Justin Torres。那本书是一部了不起的作品。我不想谈论太多，因为我只读了三分之一。但它让我想起了我真正的，我最喜欢的书，Juan Rufo 的《佩德罗·巴拉莫》(Pedro Paramo)。那本书启发了加西亚·马尔克斯写《百年孤独》
is this book called Blackouts by Justin Torres. And that book is like an amazing piece of work. I don't wanna talk too much about it because I'm only like a third of the way through it. But it reminds me of my actual, my true favorite book, which is Pedro Paramo by Juan Rufo. And that is like this book that inspired Gabriel Garcia Marquez to write 100 years of solitude
等等。所以它很短，实际上，《佩德罗·巴拉莫》。只有 110 页左右，但它简直完美。每一个句子都是完美的，完美的，完美的，完美的。他们实际上刚拍了一部关于它的 Netflix 电影，我吓得不敢看。但它是 Rodrigo Prieta，很多伟大作品的摄影指导。所以我猜它看起来很美。
and all that stuff. And so it's very short, actually, Petra Parama. It's only like 110 pages or something, but it is just perfect. Every sentence is perfect, perfect, perfect, perfect. And they actually just made a Netflix movie about it that I am horrified to watch. But it is Rodrigo Prieta, the director of photography for a lot of great things. So I imagine it looks beautiful.
我只是害怕他们对故事做了什么。是的，我的意思是，如果对你来说大部分魔力是完美的句子。Netflix 电影中没有办法传达完美的句子。是的，不幸的是。但这太棒了。好吧，这两个非常有趣。所以是 Justin Torres 的《停电》。
I'm just afraid of what they did with the story. Yeah, I mean, especially if so much of the magic for you is the perfect sentences. There's no way to convey perfect sentences in a Netflix movie. Yeah, unfortunately. But that's awesome. Well, these are two very interesting. So it's Black Outs by Justin Torres.
Justin Torres。还有 Carl Phillips 的诗集《散落北方的雪》。谢谢你，Jason。是的，当然。哦，是的，还有《跳跳蛙》。然后当然是《跳跳蛙》，抱歉，不要忘记，不要把《跳跳蛙》排除在外，
Justin Torres. And Scattered Snows to the North, poems by Carl Phillips. Thank you, Jason. Yep, of course. Oh yeah, and Hoppity Frog. And then Hoppity Frog, of course. Sorry, not to forget, not to leave Hoppity Frog out of this,
但《跳跳蛙》听起来很令人愉快。好吧，那么，最后一位要谈论他正在读的书的贡献者是 Joe Rosenberg。嘿，Joe。嘿，Roman，怎么样？我很好。我真的很兴奋，大家，就像我们本来都要上来，然后人们要离开，继续他们一天的制作。
but Hoppity Frog sounds delightful. All right, well, so our last contributor that's going to talk about books that he's reading is Joe Rosenberg. Hey, Joe. Hey, Roman, how's it going? I'm good. I'm really excited by everyone's, like, we were going to all come on and then people are going to drop off and go on with their day of production.
我注意到每个人都还在 Zoom 上，因为他们太，就像，被人们谈论他们喜欢的书所吸引，这太棒了。所以你现在正在忙于什么书？所以我偶然发现了一篇关于埃里克·亚当斯和，你知道，腐败丑闻的文章。我一直很着迷，并且一直对腐败人物，特别是政治体系中更腐败部分的更腐败政客如此随意地腐败的方式感到着迷。你知道我的意思吗？就像，这被认为是理所当然的，这就是世界运作的方式。所以他们，他们也这样在世界上运作。
And I've noticed that everyone is still on the Zoom because they are so, like, entranced by people talking about the books that they like, which is amazing. So what book are you sort of occupied with right now? So I was coming across this article about Eric Adams and, you know, the corruption scandal. And I was always fascinated and have always been fascinated by the way corruptrupt figures particularly more corrupt politicians in more corrupt parts of the political system are so casually corrupt Do you know what I mean? And like it's just it's just taken for granted that this is the way the world works And so they were they they work their way in the world like this, too
但后来他们变得有点太引人注目了。所以当他们低调时对他们有效的事情，比如不再对他们有效了，对吧？完全正确。他们有点被抓了个措手不及，就像：“你是什么意思，我不能用这架土耳其航空公司的飞机？”但我发现的这篇文章推荐了一本 1905 年的书，叫《坦慕尼协会的普朗克特》(Plunket of Tammany Hall)。我不知道这是否出现过，就像，你知道，在你自己在 99PI 或《权力掮客》内容中的操纵中。但坦慕尼协会，当然，是
But then they get a little too high profile And so the things that work for them when they were low profile like don't work for them anymore, right? Totally. And they kind of get caught by surprise being like, what do you mean I can't use this Turkish airline? But this article I found recommended a book from 1905 called Plunket of Tammany Hall. And I don't know if this has come up at all, like, you know, in your own kind of maneuvering through 99PI or the power broker stuff. But Tammany Hall, of course, was like
那个运行民主党政治和爱尔兰裔美国人政治，因此也是上世纪之交纽约市政治的大型政治机器。所以 19 世纪末，20 世纪初，甚至在富兰克林·罗斯福和其他几个人最终把钉子钉在它的棺材上之前，它甚至把触角延伸到了 20 世纪中期。而普朗克特，乔治·华盛顿·普朗克特，是坦慕尼协会里这个庞大机器的政客。
the great big political machine that ran democratic politics and Irish American politics and therefore a lot of New York City politics around the turn of the last century. So late 19th century, early 20th century, and even extended kind of its tentacles into the mid 20th century before it finally kind of FDR and a few other people kind of finally put the nails in its coffin. And Plunkett, George Washington Plunkett was this big machine politician in Tammany Hall.
那个在世纪之交操纵民主党政治、爱尔兰裔美国人政治，进而影响了大量纽约市政治的庞大政治机器。它存在于19世纪末、20世纪初，甚至将其触角延伸到了20世纪中期，直到富兰克林·罗斯福和其他一些人最终将其彻底终结。乔治·华盛顿·普伦基特就是坦慕尼协会中一位举足轻重的机器政客。
He had every single thing. So he was like, I'm looking at his Wikipedia page here. So like, you know, member of the New York Senate for the 17th district, member of the New York Senate for the 11th district, member of the New York State Assembly for the 17th district again, and like all these other local and state offices, you know, whether he was good at any of these jobs is totally unclear.
他拥有一切。我正在看他的维基百科页面，比如，他是纽约州参议院第17选区议员、第11选区议员、纽约州众议院第17选区议员，还有其他各种地方和州政府职位。至于他是否胜任这些工作，完全不清楚。
The point is that- It was not required of Tammany Hall for sure that you were good at the job. No, exactly. And the, you know, he didn't, he had a sixth grade education. He was born to Irish American parents on a hill in what was would become Central Park.
重点是，坦慕尼协会绝对不要求你胜任工作。没错，正是如此。而且他只有六年级学历。他出生在爱尔兰裔美国人家庭，出生地就在后来成为中央公园的一座小山上。
You know, he's buried in that, I forget what it's called, but I only lived in New York for two years, so apologies. But that famous cemetery in Queens that you always see in the movies where you see the tombstones in the foreground and Manhattan in the background. So, New York born and bred and died. And unlike a lot of Tammany men,
他被安葬在那个——我忘了叫什么名字了，我在纽约只住了两年，抱歉。就是电影里经常看到的皇后区那个著名的墓地，前景是墓碑，背景是曼哈顿。所以，他是土生土长的纽约人，也死在那里。和许多坦慕尼协会的人不同，
he was very open about the way things worked. He liked, he was a talker, he liked to talk. And he would kind of hold court at this shoeshine stand at the local courthouse and kind of just have these kind of soliloquies prepared about just different aspects of politics and his thoughts and insights and wisdoms on politics and this reporter named William Reardon finally just decided that he put all of this guy's talks together in a book and he just called it Plunket of Tammany Hall. And it's just kind of his thoughts about this and that, about like, you know, why a politician
他对于事情的运作方式非常坦诚。他喜欢说话，是个健谈的人。他会在当地法院的擦鞋摊前高谈阔论，准备好各种独白，谈论政治的方方面面，以及他对政治的思考、见解和智慧。一位名叫威廉·里尔登的记者最终决定把这个人的所有谈话整理成书，并将其命名为《坦慕尼协会的普朗基特》。书中记录了他对各种事情的看法，比如为什么政客
should not drink, why a politician should never, his clothes should never be too fancy, you know, things like that. But also a lot about his defense of the Tammany system and kind of his defense of what we would think of as corruption. But he just saw as in some ways, like, what do you mean? This is the way the world works. How else will anything get done? Right?
不应该喝酒，为什么政客的穿着不应该太花哨等等。书中还有很多关于他为坦慕尼体系辩护的内容，以及他为我们所认为的腐败所做的辩护。但他只是觉得，这有什么问题？这就是世界运作的方式。不然还能怎么把事情办成呢？对吧？
And so there's this one chapter called the curse of civil service reform. He hates civil service reform. And throughout this little book, he just takes every moment to talk about how awful it is and how it's ruining New York, right? And civil service reform being, of course, that you can't use the spoil system. In order to become a civil servant, you can't just be plunked into the office as a sinecure. You have to take a test and stuff like that.
书中有一章叫《公务员制度改革的诅咒》。他痛恨公务员制度改革。在整本书里，他一有机会就说这有多糟糕，说它正在毁掉纽约。当然，公务员制度改革意味着你不能再使用分赃制度。为了成为公务员，你不能只是被安插进一个闲职，你必须参加考试之类的。
Take a test and yeah, earn it. It's supposed to be a meritocracy, for sure. Right, and so you have to imagine Plunket sitting at his shoeshine stand and just kind of holding forth on this. It's an outrage. What did the people mean when they voted for Tammany? What is representative government anyhow?
参加考试，没错，凭本事获得职位。这本应该是任人唯贤的，对吧？没错，所以你可以想象普朗基特坐在擦鞋摊前高谈阔论的样子。这简直是暴行。人们投票给坦慕尼协会时是什么意思？代议制政府到底是什么？
Is it all fake that this is a government of the people, by the people, and for the people? If it isn't fake, then why isn't the people's voice obeyed and Tammany men put in all the offices? You know, when the people elected Tammany, they knew just what they were doing. We didn't put up any false pretenses. We didn't go in for humbug civil service and all that rot. We stood as we have always stood for rewarding the men that won the victory. They call that the spoil system.
难道“民有、民治、民享”的政府全是假的吗？如果不是假的，那为什么不听从人民的声音，让坦慕尼协会的人担任所有职位？当人们选举坦慕尼协会时，他们很清楚自己在做什么。我们没有虚伪的借口。我们不搞那些虚伪的公务员制度和废话。我们一贯主张奖励那些赢得胜利的人。他们把这称为分赃制度。
All right, Tammany is the spoil system. And when we go in, we fire every anti-Tammany man from office that can be fired under the law. It's an elastic sort of law, and you can bet it will be stretched to the limit. Right? And, you know, it's just kind of just law, and you can bet it will be stretched to the limit. Right? And, you know, it's just,
没错，坦慕尼协会就是分赃制度。当我们上台时，我们会解雇法律允许范围内所有反坦慕尼协会的人。这是一种弹性法律，你可以打赌它会被用到极致。对吧？而且，你知道，这只是……
and he kind of just like goes on like that for different things. Well, this is really fascinating. I picked this up, this, it's a short little book that I picked up on your recommendation. I have not cracked it open yet, so now I'm really intrigued to start on it. So thank you so much, Joe, I appreciate it.
他就是这样谈论各种事情的。这真的很有趣。我根据你的推荐买了这本小书。我还没翻开过，现在我真的很有兴趣开始读了。所以非常感谢你，乔，我很感激。
Wait, so Roman, you've gotten all of our recommendations, but like, what are you reading right now, besides The Power Broker, of course? So I read a lot for the show, so I don't have a lot of time. I'm reading a lot of books, like I have to blur books for folks, and it's very nice thing that people care about my opinion
等等，罗曼，你已经收到了我们所有的推荐，但除了《权力掮客》之外，你现在在读什么？我为节目读了很多书，所以我没有太多时间。我读了很多书，比如我得为别人写书评，人们关心我的意见并想把它印在书封上，这是一件很好的事情，
and wanna put it on the cover of a book to be sold, so I read a lot of those. But the one I've been reading kind of for myself recently is John McPhee's Pine Barrens, which John McPhee, if you don't know him, he's sort of this master of creative nonfiction. I mostly read nonfiction. I just can't, there's something about a block in my head that makes it so I can't read a lot of stories about made-up people because in the end I just feel the authorship too much and I just like to learn about history and use the time to learn about history. But the Pine Barrens is a very, it's from 1968, it's a very sort of essayistic, somewhat
所以我读了很多那样的书。但我最近为自己读的一本书是约翰·麦克菲的《松林荒原》。如果你不了解约翰·麦克菲，他是创意非虚构写作的大师。我主要读非虚构作品。我脑子里有个障碍，让我无法阅读关于虚构人物的故事，因为最后我总能感觉到作者的痕迹太重，我更喜欢学习历史，利用时间来了解历史。《松林荒原》写于1968年，它非常具有散文风格，
poetic but full of facts, just tale about this area of New Jersey, which is extremely confusing. Like, it's this very kind of harsh and barren land in the most densely populated state in the Union. And it has a poetry to the place and then therefore it allows for a certain kind of poetry in the writing of it. And it's extremely nonlinear. I just think that he's kind of a master of a certain type of creative nonfiction, which
充满事实，讲述了新泽西州这个极其令人困惑的地区。它是联邦人口最稠密州里的一片非常严酷荒凉的土地。这个地方有一种诗意，因此在写作中也允许某种诗意。它非常非线性。我认为他是某种创意非虚构写作的大师，
I don't read a lot of. And so I've been trying to dig into John McPhee and sort of get myself a little more versed in his library, which I think it's kind of like not really a blind spot for me because I've read plenty, but he's written so much that I have not read that I've been trying to attack it. So I would recommend picking up The Pie and Perence by John McPhee. It's really working for me. And that's it for all of us. So thank you everyone for listening to this and I hope you got a lot of good book recommendations. I mean, I'm super into the books that people
我读得不多。所以我一直在尝试深入研究约翰·麦克菲，让自己对他的作品集更熟悉一些。我觉得这对我来说不算是一个盲点，因为我读过很多，但他写得太多了，我还没读完，所以我一直在努力攻克。所以我建议大家去读约翰·麦克菲的《松林荒原》。它对我很有启发。我们今天的节目就到这里。感谢大家的收听，希望你们得到了很多好的书单推荐。我是真的很喜欢大家
suggested. And so thanks. I really appreciate it. Become a SiriusXM Podcast plus subscriber to get ad free listening and more bonus episodes. We really enjoyed doing this one and we're looking forward to more in 2025. Get in touch if you have any suggestions or things you want to hear from us. This episode was mixed by Martin Gonzalez music by Swan Real. Cathy Tu is our executive producer, Kurt Kolstad is the digital director, Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Barube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Lay, Lasha Madone, Joe Rosenberg, Kelly Prime, Jacob Medina Gleason, and me, Roman Mars. The
推荐的书。所以谢谢你们。我真的很感激。成为SiriusXM Podcast Plus订阅用户，享受无广告收听和更多额外剧集。我们非常喜欢制作这一期，并期待在2025年带来更多内容。如果你有任何建议或想听的内容，请联系我们。本期节目由马丁·冈萨雷斯混音，音乐由Swan Real创作。凯西·图是我们的执行制片人，库尔特·科尔斯塔德是数字总监，德莱尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。团队其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝、杰森·德莱昂、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、薇薇安·莱、拉莎·马多内、乔·罗森伯格、凯利·普莱姆、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森，以及我，罗曼·马斯。这
99% visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful. Uptown. Oakland, California. You can find us on Blue Sky as well as our own Discord server. There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
99% Invisible的标志是由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作的。我们是SiriusXM播客家族的一员，现在总部位于北边六个街区外的潘多拉大厦。地点在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区。你可以在Blue Sky上找到我们，也可以加入我们的Discord服务器。在99PI.org上可以找到相关链接以及99PI的所有往期节目。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。